the fears that russia is on the brink of
a full-scale invasion of ukraine our
holly williams and her team are near the
front lines in eastern ukraine where
they witnessed heavy artillery fire this
morning
there has been a conflict with the
separatists there since 2014 suspected
russian military vehicles have been
spotted in the two breakaway regions of
ukraine that russia's vladimir putin is
now recognized as independent drawing
international condemnation this morning
russia said its recognition of
independence includes areas held by
ukrainian forces holly williams joins us
now to bring us up to date holly please
be careful out there and good morning to
you vladimir putin has a very
interesting way of looking at territory
it seems
yeah good morning gail ukraine has
accused russia's president vladimir
putin of trying to revive the soviet
union and the country's president is
asking for international support now but
remember russian-backed separatists in
those breakaway regions of ukraine that
president putin has now recognized as
independent are already fighting a war
against ukrainian forces and we've been
to the trenches of that bloody conflict
we traveled to the front line by truck
with ukrainian soldiers until we were
ordered into this bunker well we were
told to stop and come underground
because apparently a local commander
says it's too dangerous right now at the
front line
when we made it to the trenches we found
a quagmire
the ukrainians say the snows melted
early this year
the mud might slow an invasion down the
soldiers told us but it won't stop it
it's normally
heavy shelling
24 hours by seven private valerie
kashkarev told us he was a businessman
before he signed up and a former
exchange student in dallas
why then would vladimir putin invade we
don't know we are on all our own land
soldiers of this country protecting our
country i don't know what's in the head
of vladimir putin i apologize
ukraine's been fighting a war against
russian-backed separatists since 2014
and now there's been a new eruption of
violence
the separatists are in the breakaway
regions of ukraine that president putin
recognized yesterday as independent
republics drawing condemnation from the
u.s and its allies
u.s officials say moscow is arming the
separatists and ukraine says they're
targeting civilian areas including the
village of novo nyativka where they seem
shell-shocked
we're on the brink of nervous breakdowns
at ekaterina absiiva and there's nowhere
to run
back in the trenches sergeant
lubomir told us ukraine needs protection
from the air and said america should
help
the us has previously ruled out sending
combat troops to ukraine but it sent
this country nearly 3 billion in
military assistance in recent years the
question now is whether what we're
seeing here is the beginning of another
russian invasion of ukraine
nate
holly williams you define what it means
to have boots on the ground thank you
for your informative and sometimes
dangerous coverage in ukraine we
appreciate you